ABOVE 50 IN A RUNOFF.
>> THAT 54 WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO
BE ABOVE 50 BUT NOT HOW HIGH.
STACEY ABRAMS ANOTHER FIGURE IN
DEMOCRATIC POLITICS LIKE BETO
O'ROURKE WHO GETS A LOT OF
ATTENTION AND A TON EVER MONEY.
SHE IS NOT WINNING RACES.
>> YOU SEE TIM RYAN AND STACEY
ABRAMS AND BETO O'ROURKE.
TIM RYAN IS A QUALITY CANDIDATE.
HE'S PROVEN HIMSELF ON THE
NATIONAL STAGE.
BETO O'ROURKE AND STACEY ABRAMS
HAVE NOT.
THEY HAVE PROVEN THEY CAN LOSE
ELECTIONS AND WASTE A LOT OF
MONEY LOSING ELECTIONS.
A NIGHT LIKE THIS WHEN YOU HAVE
A DESCRIBE A DISAPPOINTING
PERFORMANCE FROM A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT REPUBLICAN SENATE
CANDIDATES, YOU WONDER HOW MUCH
OF THAT MONEY THAT FLOWED INTO
STACEY ABR